Twilight Princess HD drops march forth  but there's more to this re-release than  shiny new graphics and a double damaging  hero mode you can use a couple different  amoeba to change the game first there's  link and Toon Link tap these amiibo on  your gamepad and you'll have your arrows  fully replenished tabs elder chic and  you'll get all your hearts back  Ganondorf will make enemies twice as  strong so using him in Hero Mode means  you take quadruple damage and finally  there's the new midna and wolf link  amiibo that launches with the game this  opens up a brand new dungeon called the  cave of shadows only wolfling can  complete this challenge which throws  tons of Twilight enemies at you amiibo  functionality adds a whole new way to  play twilight princess and there isn't  much longer to go before the game comes  out in the meantime you can link with  GameSpot for all the best news and  reviews and Hyrule